und damit kommen wir zum letzten
tagesordnungspunkt heute da geht es um
die konsequenzen aus dem paritätischen
armutsbericht der paritätische
gesamtverband hat vergangene woche
seinen armutsbericht vorgelegt und
feststellen müssen dass die armutsquote
so hoch ist wie noch nie zuvor und die
linksfraktion hat hier deswegen eine
aktuelle stunde beantragt um darüber zu
sprechen und für die linksfraktion
spricht jetzt auch die parteivorsitzende
der linken janine wissler
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
die linke hat diese aktuelle stunde
beantragt damit sich der deutsche
bundestag mit dem armutsbericht des
paritätischen wohlfahrtsverbandes und
der zunehmenden armut in diesem land
befasst und vor allem weil endlich was
getan werden muss gegen die wachsende
soziale ungleichheit die armut in
deutschland hat mit einer quote von 16,6
prozent
einen traurigen neuen prüfstand erreicht
13 8 millionen menschen leben in diesem
land in abend in diesem gleichen land
das sind 600.000 mehr als vor der
pandemie jedes fünfte kind in
deutschland lebt in armut und diese
zahlen meine damen und herren wurden
2021 erhoben wohlgemerkt vor der
aktuellen teuerungswelle und den
drastischen preisanstieg bei energie und
lebensmitteln
das betrifft menschen die auf die
grundsicherung angewiesen sind aber auch
sehr viele die trotz erwerbsarbeit arm
sind die in prekären jobs mit viel zu
wenig gehalt arbeiten in teilzeit
und als aufstocker diese sitzungswoche
ist die letzte vor der sommerpause und
viele von ihnen werden in den nächsten
wochen urlaub machen sie werden andere
länder bereisen aber viele menschen in
diesem land können sich das überhaupt
nicht mehr leisten nicht mal alle paar
jahre ein paar tage in urlaub ist
überhaupt nicht zu denken bei menschen
die mahlzeiten ausfallen lassen um
irgendwie über den monat zu kommen die
auf tafel angewiesen sind und die
reserven vieler menschen die finanziell
wie die körperlichen und psychischen
sind sich mit permanenten mangel und
sorgen zu arrangieren sind längst
aufgebraucht wir wissen krankheit macht
arm und armut macht krank und das darf
doch nicht sein in einem so reichen land
ich habe den bundeskanzler diese woche
in der regierungsbefragung gefragt ob er
denkt dass man als erwachsener von 449
euro das ist der aktuelle
hartz-iv-regelsatz über den monat kommen
kann und ich habe ihn gefragt ob 285
euro im monat für ein kind reichen
leider hat er die frage nicht
beantwortet er sagte dass wir uns einig
sein dass das nicht viel geld sei das
war aber nicht meine frage hartz4 muss
so sieht es das gesetz nämlich vor das
existenzminimum abdecken wenn also ein
bundeskanzler auf die frage ob hartz 4
zum leben reicht nicht klar mit ja
antworten kann dann zweifelt
offensichtlich auch er daran dass hartz
iv bezieherinnen und bezieher in
deutschland genug zum leben haben und
zur erinnerung der hartz iv regelsatz
wurde in diesem jahr um drei euro erhöht
bei kindern waren zwei euro und das ist
angesichts der drastisch gestiegenen
preise faktisch eine kürzung stadt die
krisen profiteure endlich stärker zu
besteuern will finanzminister linda aber
jetzt auch noch bei
langzeiterwerbslosen kürzen und das
meine damen und herren lehnen wir strikt
ab das darf nicht durchkommt
herlyn beschwört die menschen auf
einsparungen ein und er spricht von fünf
jahren der knappheit grüße nach sylt in
diesem zusammenhang und damit meinte
offensichtlich mit der knappheit vor
allem die die ohnehin schon wenig für
immobilienkäufer hingegen soll es
nämlich steuererleichterungen geben und
bald diese woche alle bei einer hochzeit
reden will ich ihnen auch die geschichte
erzählen von einer nicht stattgefundenen
hochzeit ich habe mir vor kurzem mit
einer jungen frau gesprochen die hat
zwei kleine kinder und sie muss
aufstocken weil ihr gehalt nicht reicht
und sie und ihr lebensgefährte haben
längere zeit geld angespart um zu
heiraten
dann gehen die waschmaschine kaputt
und die beiden haben bis heute nicht
geheiratet
wohlgemerkt wir reden hier nicht über
eine feier wir reden hier auch nicht
mein kleid wir reden hier nicht über
sylt und auch nicht mal flitzer wochen
es geht um die gebühren für das
standesamt für urkunden und die änderung
von dokumenten die diese familie
finanziell überfordert und das ist die
situation von vielen menschen in diesem
land und viele menschen berichten von
ihrer scham arm zu sein von der scham
ihren kindern nichts bieten zu können
dass man selbst einladung ablehnen muss
weil man sich im restaurant kneipe
besucher nicht leisten können nein nicht
diese menschen müssten sich schämen für
ihre armut die unternehmen müssten sich
schämen die menschen mit niedriglöhnen
abspeisen ich sage auch eine
bundesregierung wo sich dafür schämen
dass sie um die armut in diesem land
weiß und einfach nicht handelt meine
damen und herren
natürlich stimmt es beim
entlastungspaket für die rentnerinnen
und rentner außen vor gelassen wo bleibt
denn die erhöhung von hartz iv wo bleibt
denn die erhöhung der regelsätze man
kann bürgergeld im koalitionsvertrag
reinschreiben formen die leute die
kindergrundsicherung haben sie aufs jahr
20 24 verschoben aber kinder haben nur
eine kindheit sie müssen jetzt handeln
und das nicht in die zukunft schieben
und das hat notwendig ist dass die rats
4 setzte sofort um 200 euro dass sie
erhöht werden die kindergrundsicherung
jetzt einen für ein kostenfreies
mittagessen in schulen und kitas wir
brauchen direkte hilfe für kleine und
mittlere einkommen und wir brauchen eine
wirksame kontrolle der energiepreise in
diesem land damit sich die
energiekonzerne nicht bereichern und
einen bundesweiten mieten deckel damit
die leute ihre miete zahlen können und
das müssen wir finanzieren durch eine
höhere besteuerung von großen gewinnen
in diesem land von großen vermögen damit
in diesem reichen land wirklich jeder in
würde leben können
13,8 millionen menschen werden zu den
armen gerechnet das heißt sie müssen mit
weniger als 60 prozent des mittleren
einkommens auskommen
darüber diskutiert jetzt der bundestag
und als nächstes spricht natürlich
public war präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen ich möchte mich zunächst
bei der linksfraktion für die aktuelle
stunde bedanken denn das bietet uns
allen gelegenheit über das wichtige
thema der armutsbekämpfung und über die
maßnahmen der bundesregierung zu
sprechen
die ergebnisse des armes berichts des
paritätischen wohlfahrtsverbands sind
erschreckend 13 8 millionen menschen in
deutschland sind laut dem bericht arm
dass es ein erschütternder rekord
in armut zu leben bedeutet am ende des
monats entscheiden zu müssen ob der
kühlschrank oder der tank leer bleibt es
ist das gefühl der angst trotz mehrerer
jobs den briefkasten zu öffnen weil da
die nächste mal umdrehen liegen könnte
aber bedeutet dass kinder nicht zu
kindergeburtstagen gehen können weil
kein geld für ein geburtstagsgeschenk
vorhanden ist armut macht krank armut
schafft leid und armut zerstört
potenziale das muss ein ende haben
kolleginnen kollegen
in den letzten jahren haben wir mehrere
krisen hintereinander erlebt die korona
pandemie der schreckliche angriffskrieg
auf die ukraine all das führt zu höheren
lebensmittelpreisen zu höheren
energiepreisen das wirkt sich natürlich
auch auf unsere gesellschaft aus daher
haben wir in den letzten jahren durch
viele teilweise aufeinander folgende
maßnahmenpaketen die menschen bei akut
bei der krise besonders unterstützt mit
hilfen in milliarden höhe von familien
für familien für selbstständige für
unternehmen für menschen im
leistungsbezug für azubis und
studierende
maßnahmen wie das kurzarbeitergeld und
die korona einzel haben uns durch die
korona pandemie gebracht und dafür
gesorgt dass gerade in diesen zeiten der
arbeitsmarkt bis heute stabil bleibt
unsere erst kürzlich beschlossene
entlastungspaket wieder einmal bonus für
kinder 200 euro einmalzahlungen für
menschen im leistungsbezug der
heizkostenzuschuss die rentenanpassung
sowie die erhöhung des mindestlohns
fangen jetzt erst an zu wirken
die strukturellen probleme von armut
lösen wir aber nicht nur durch
einzelmaßnahmen alleine wir müssen das
problem bei der wurzel packen das
armutsrisiko in unserer gesellschaft ist
ungleich verteilt es gibt gruppen bei
denen die wahrscheinlichkeit höher ist
in armut zu geraten
und es gibt unterschiede in den
unterschied bundesländern und den
regionen auch das bestätigt der
paritätische armutsbericht besonders von
armut betroffen sind kinder und
jugendliche sowie rentnerinnen und
rentner die drittstärkste gruppe und
darauf habt meine kollegin wissler
darauf hingewiesen stellte erwerbs armut
da auf die ich mich besonders beziehen
möchte menschen die tagtäglich frühe
aufstehen hat arbeiten gehen und am ende
von ihrem lohn doch nicht leben können
das darf nicht sein kolleginnen und
kollegen
selbstständige ist sind unter den
erwerbstätigen in armut mit 13 1 prozent
besonders hart betroffen aber auch unter
den abhängigen beschäftigten steigt die
armut zu zahlen der kampf gegen prekäre
beschäftigung der einsatz für gute
arbeit und faire löhne von denen die
menschen auch gut leben können das ist
und bleibt das nachhaltigste mittel
gegen armut im oktober steigt der
mindestlohn auf 12 euro seit dem ersten
juli es darf 10 eur 45 angestiegen
gerade bei denen die viel arbeiten aber
wenig geld haben ist das eine
lohnerhöhung von bis zu 20 prozent
die erhöhung des mindestlohns ist ein
wichtiger schritt im kampf gegen erwerbs
an
wir werden zudem aber auch die
tarifbindung stärken und die
mitbestimmung voranbringen den schutz
vor armut trotz erwerbstätigkeit
ist eine hohe tarifbindung
mit der konzertierten aktion zu der der
kanzler anfang dieser woche geladen hat
hatten wir alle akteurinnen und akteuren
auf den arbeitsmarkt unter und suchen
gemeinsam nach lösungen für die probleme
unserer zeit und ich bin olaf scholz
sehr dankbar für diese kraftanstrengung
um armut nachhaltig zu bekämpfen müssen
wir das problem bei der wurzel packen
eine gesellschaft ohne armut ist keine
utopie sondern ein sozialdemokratisches
projekt in der ampelkoalition handeln
wir ab hut durch einzelmaßnahmen wir
gehen jedoch auch mit dem mindestlohn
der kindergrundsicherung dem bürger geld
und vielen mehr armut ganz konkret an
den ursachen an um genau auf diesen
zweig kommt dass jetzt auf vielen dank
für ihre aufmerksamkeit und
republik war das für die spd fraktion in
der aktuellen stunde welche konsequenzen
denn hier die politik aus dem
paritätischen armutsbericht 2022 ziehen
möchte und jetzt kommt's motiviert klein
für die irritation
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
panik vor unvorhergesehenen kosten
schaan
einsamkeit keine möglichkeit zu sparen
zukunftsangst ein verwalten ständigen
mangels das sind schilderungen von
menschen die armut erfahren haben sie
sind im aktuellen paritätischen
armutsbericht festgehalten und erst
gestern habe ich selbst mit einigen der
dort zitierten menschen gesprochen ihren
erfahrungen möchte ich hier und heute
eine stimme geben im bundestag sprechen
wir oft über armut hilfen und
entlastungen doch nur die wenigsten von
uns wissen was es bedeutet wirklich arm
zu sein
armut ist kein abstraktes problem keine
zahl keine statistik hinter armut
städten persönliche schicksale armut hat
viele gesichter und leider viel zu oft
auch ein kindergesicht
besonders von armut betroffen sind
kinderreiche familien und
alleinerziehende
sie treffen die derzeitigen
preissteigerungen besonders rad und als
cdu/csu haben wir deshalb bereits vor
monaten sofortmaßnahmen zur entlastung
von rc allein erziehenden gefordert die
ampel hat das abgelehnt dabei brauchen
wir dringend wirksame maßnahmen und
einer verschärfung von kinderarmut in
zeiten steigender preise entgegen zu
wirken jetzt
jetzt muss gehandelt werden strukturelle
veränderungen im jahr 2025 kommen
deutlich zu spät
der bericht des paritätischen
wohlfahrtsverbandes zeigt zudem mehr als
jeder fünfte von armut betroffene ist in
rente
und trotz aller kritik weigert sich die
bundesregierung menschen mit kleinen
renten in den entlastungs paketen zu
berücksichtigen
auch bei den neuen angedacht und
einmalzahlungen werden die rentnerinnen
und rentner wieder außen vor gelassen
ich habe es an dieser stelle schon
einmal gesagt wer es mit der bekämpfung
von altersarmut ernst mit der staat
nicht bei bedürftigen ländern als
hypothese vollendet
viele csu fordert seit monaten gemeinsam
mit den wohlfahrtsverbänden älteren
menschen mit geringen hat das bezügen zu
entlassen ist und
ich glaub ich glaube bei der regierung
ist man merkt schon hier wird so wird's
wieder wird's wieder ein bisschen norte
man merkt der aber muss man muss einfach
ein bisschen grundsätzlicher werden bei
ihnen
der sozialstaat der sozialstaat ist
dafür da die schwächsten zu stützen
nicht die stärksten anstatt das geld
dort ankommen wo sie am dringendsten
benötigt werden möchte die ampel fast
alle ein bisschen beglückend natürlich
mit neuen staatsschulden auf kosten der
jungen generation selbst jene die hier
auf der regierungsbank sitzen minister
und staatssekretäre halten also 300 euro
in die kostenpauschale während gerade
gehört senioren ihre mahlzeiten bei den
lieferdiensten rationieren müssen von
23,6 milliarden euro entlastung für
privathaushalte fließen not bricht
gerade einmal 2 milliarden euro an
bedürftige während die ampel also
großzügig geldgeschenke auf pump an
gruppen verteilt die sie gar nicht
benötigen gibt es menschen in diesem
land die bereits jetzt nur noch wenige
zimmer in der wohnung heizen aus angst
vor dem kostenschock im herbst wenn sie
nicht war dankbar sich merkwürdiges
verständnis von respekt dass die spd da
fliegt
der paritätische wohlfahrtsverband
fordert die regierung zu recht auf ein
wirksames
nachhaltiges und vor allem zielgerichtet
das entlastungs paket vorzulegen den
schließen wir uns an weniger gibt keine
politik auf pump mehr zielgerichtete
hilfen für bedürftige ein wirksamer
schutzschirm für armutsgefährdete
haushalte und vor allem keiner
lebenswert lebensfernen ratschläge noch
möglichst kurz und kalt zu duschen
vielen dank
nächste rednerin für die fraktion
bündnis 90/die grünen stefanie
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kollegin die letzte debatte vor der
sommerpause nimmt an zu drängendsten
probleme aktuell ins visier armut ich
bin froh dass wir noch die gelegenheit
haben uns mit dem armutsbericht des
paritätischen gesamtverbandes zu
beschäftigen denn die befunde sind
erschreckend so ist es auch nicht
verwunderlich dass unter den betroffenen
menschen der zorn wächst hey ich bin an
39 jahre und habe die schnauze voll
ich lebe von hartz 4 und es reicht ganz
einfach nicht mit diesen worten
beginnt denn auch der erste tweet unter
dem hashtag ich bin armut zu betroffen
unter diesem hashtag kann man von vielen
ausgrenzung erfahrungen von not und von
echter angst lesen ich bin sehr dankbar
dass ich diese menschen organisieren und
ihre stimme erheben und ich bin auch
dankbar dass diese menschen bereit waren
mit mir in einen austausch zu starten
ihre erfahrungen sind die persönlichen
gesichter dessen was wir im
armutsbericht des paritätischen lesen
können
zusammen wird eines sehr klar wir müssen
jetzt handeln
wir haben ein anderes problem und das
nicht erst seit der pandemie und den
stetig steigenden preisen durch den
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine vielmehr
haben die letzten zwei jahre die
situation dramatisch verschlimmert
13,8 millionen menschen leben in armut
so viele wie noch nie
das sind 600.000 mehr als vor der
pandemie
doch die auswirkungen der pandemie und
inflation treffen nicht alle gleich dem
einen fallen 30 cent mehr für das brot
beim einkauf überhaupt nicht auf für
manche bringt das den detailliert
geplanten wocheneinkauf komplett
durcheinander
menschen mit geringen einkommen treffen
die steigenden preise besonders rat
für viele ist das nicht nur
vorübergehend einen großen teil der
menschen in armut machen die sogenannten
nichterwerbspersonen aus zwei drittel
das sind vor allem
alters und erwerbsminderungsrentner
innen unter 18-jährige oder auch andere
personen die dem arbeitsmarkt nicht
kurzfristig zur verfügung stehen zum
beispiel weil sie angehörige pflegen
diese personen können wir nicht über
arbeitsmarktorientierte maßnahmen aus
der armut holen wir brauchen eine
umfassende strategie um konsequent am
ziel der armut zur abschaffung zu
arbeiten
wir brauchen eine wohnungs und
mietenpolitik die dem rechnung trägt
öffentlicher verkehr ist nicht nur klima
gerecht er ist auch sozial gerecht doch
er muss ausgebaut werden und bezahlbar
sein
krankheit und pflegebedürftigkeit dürfen
nicht länger
und genauso brauchen wir
sozialleistungen die würde und achten um
soziale teilhabe sicherstellen letzten
freitag habe ich in einem twitter space
über zweieinhalb stunden mit betroffenen
menschen gesprochen die schon jetzt als
betroffen sind die geschichten die sie
erzählen machen sprachlos sie können
ihre ausgaben für kindergesundheit
lebensmittel mobilität und
lebensnotwendige waren nicht mehr
bezahlen die not ist überall zu spüren
die organisatorinnen des twitter spaces
führen immer wieder umfragen durch im
jahr 20 22 sagen über 80 prozent der
teilnehmer innen dass sie mit dem
regelsatz nicht auskommen um ihre
lebensmittel kosten zu decken bei 65
prozent reicht er nicht für eine
ausreichende gesundheitspflege und bei
über 80 prozent reicht es nicht die
stromkosten zu zahlen mit der einführung
des bürgergeldes müssen wir endlich
einen echten wandel einleiten wir haben
drei aufgaben wir müssen jetzt die
folgende inflation auffangen deshalb
brauchen wir in einem weiteren
entlastungspaket einem aufschlag auf die
regelsätze der die preissteigerung seit
juni 21 aufhängt die ermittlung der
regelsätze hat aber ein ganz
grundsätzliches problem weil sie immer
die vergangenheit betrachtet ist die
inflation des laufenden jahres nicht
abgebildet deshalb brauchen wir eine
reserve im regelsatz von preissteigerung
und genau so müssen wir ganz
grundsätzlich etwas am system ändern das
zukünftige bürgergeld muss deutlich
höhere und inflations feste regelsetzung
fassen es ist deswegen gut dass wir
heute hier über dieses problem sprechen
wir können alle mithelfen um die
menschen zu unterstützen und die ärmsten
in diesem land schnell und zielgerichtet
unterstützen zu können hören wir auf die
die es betrifft vielen dank
fordert stefan häfner für bündnis 90 die
grünen sie sitzt im ausschuss für arbeit
und soziales wie auch die nächste
rednerin geräte von der afg fraktion die
sich hier auch nochmal zum armutsbericht
äußern wird der letzte
tagesordnungspunkt hier vor der
sommerpause des plenums
wir waren das noch gut
sehr geehrte vorsitzende sehr geehrte
damen und herren
ist sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
entschuldigung
man kommt damit realität in unserem land
nicht länger vorbei im angeblich besten
deutschland aller zeiten gibt es mehr
arme menschen als je zuvor der
armutsbericht des paritätischen
wohlfahrtsverbandes spricht es aus die
armut steigt auch noch fast 14 millionen
menschen in unserem land sind von armut
betroffen die armutsquote nicht somit
bei fast 17 prozent und wenn man in die
eu statt 60 er guckt dann sind es sogar
über 20 prozent das heißt ungefähr jede
fünfte im land ist arm und da sind die
folgen der aktuelle inflation und des
sich abzeichnenden gas-notstand es noch
gar nicht mit eingerichtet das heißt wir
werden mit großer wahrscheinlichkeit
noch ärmer werden der ins negativ
gedrehte handelsbilanzüberschuss
bestätigt diesen abstieg in der
streckenweise es ergibt sich somit ein
völlig anderes bild als unsere geben
bisher bisher immer vermitteln wollten
und die medien haben dabei fleißig
mitgemacht mir ist erst noch vor kurzem
von einer bekannten journalistin
entgegengehalten wurden dass es uns so
gut in deutschland geht wie lange nicht
mehr und ein großer teil der medien muss
sich den vorwurf gefallen lassen dass
patienten schüttdorf vom reichen
deutschland sehr lange mit gestützt zu
haben
[Applaus]
denn diese entwicklung ist nicht neu ist
sie beschleunigt sich gerade nur aber
bergab mit dem wohlstand geht es schon
seit über 15 jahren
der vorwurf den sich die jetzige
bundesregierung genauso machen los
bewusst wie zuvor die unglücklichen
merkel regierungen sie haben das problem
nicht zur kenntnis nehmen wollen in
ihrer großmannssucht haben sie sich
lieber der weltrettung gewidmet anstatt
sich den nöten der deutschen bürger
zuzuwenden und das geht nun nicht mehr
jetzt kann auch die ampel nicht länger
die augen vor dem elend im eigenen land
verschließen der gasnotstand am gas
hängen über 50 prozent unserer heizungen
ist unzweifelhaft ein extremes
zusätzliches erschwernis dass die armut
in diesem land noch verstärken wird
viele menschen können nach heutigem
stand ihrer heizungs nachzahlungen nicht
mehr leisten viele lassen jetzt und
mahlzeiten aus ich schon gesagt worden
viele frieren und richtiges so man wird
nachfolgen und dann die große mentale
depression die depression ist inzwischen
eine der häufigsten erkrankungen alter
menschen geworden ihre suizidrate ist
mit abstand die höchste von allen
bevölkerungsgruppen und der anstieg der
suizidraten hat sich ziemlich parallel
zum anstieg der altersarmut entwickelt
nach eu statistik sind fast 30 prozent
unserer alten arm die meisten davon drin
r und unsere rentner sind darum bei
ihrer renten so niedrig sind sie gehören
zu den niedrigsten in westeuropa
deswegen brauchen wir dringend eine
effektive rentenreform die sich nicht
mit haltelinien begnügt sondern die
unseren rentnern wieder ein würdiges
altern
wir sind österreich dänemark schweden
niederlande italien und selbst in
frankreich und natürlich erst recht in
der schweiz eine selbstverständlichkeit
ist wenn doch die regierung all die
gelder die sie in klima und weltrettung
steckt einfach dafür verwenden würde das
unsere alten menschen wieder am
gesellschaftlichen leben teilhaben
können
wieder mal eine tasse tasse kaffee außer
haus trinken vielleicht sogar irgendwann
mal wieder ins kino oder ins theater
gehen können das wäre doch was teilhabe
ist ihnen doch sonst so wichtig doch
nicht nur für randgruppen es muss doch
auch für die große gruppe der menschen
gelten die unser land aufgebaut haben
dessen reichtümer sie jetzt so
leichtsinnig verspielen schon lange ist
bekannt dass auch viele kinder bei uns
in armut aufwachsen dasselbe gilt für
viele single haushalte und für fast zehn
prozent unsere beschäftigten sie
arbeiten zum teil sogar vollzeit und
können davon nicht leben auf die
migration hat die armut im land
verschärft sie ist in doppelter hinsicht
zu einer großen bürde geworden
einerseits hinterlässt sich viele
migranten den armut die hier ihr glück
zu finden hofften und andererseits
erhöht zu den lohndruck auf die
niedriglohn segmente in unserer
wirtschaft und erhöht so die altersarmut
auch in anderen bevölkerungsteilen
einwanderung kann in wirtschaftlicher
hinsicht nur deshalb funktionieren wenn
die ankommenden menschen hoch
qualifiziert sind und direkt in einen
vorhandenen job zu wandern meine damen
und herren ist also zeit höchste zeit
die prioritäten neu zu ordnen und die
bürger wieder in den mittelpunkt der
politik zu stellen und das funktioniert
indem man die wirtschaft er tüchtig
indem er die wirtschaft erstatten lässt
denn das ist die wirtschaft eine damen
und herren nicht die politik die
wohlstand schafft
und ein kleiner tipp der gasnotstand der
angekündigte wäre sehr wohl vermeidbar
sie haben zwei möglichkeiten entweder
sie drehen nord stream 2 auf oder sie
holen endlich die fehlende turbine
führen dort stritt 1 zurück trotz des
widerspruchs der ukraine und dann haben
wir auch alle wieder dass kein geschenk
gerrit hui hat hier noch einmal
gefordert dass doch gas über die
gaspipeline south stream 112 gefördert
werden soll ob gestern gab es hier schon
eine debatte darüber jens trainer
spricht jetzt für die fdp-fraktion er
ist für seine fraktion sprecher für
bürgergeld
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir haben jetzt viel in der debatte
verschiedene armutsbericht
gehört einzelschicksale wurden berichtet
und wir schreiben auch viele bürgerinnen
und bürger aus meinem wahlkreis und
fragen wie komme ich am ende des monats
über die runde was macht die
bundesregierung für mich was noch nicht
erwähnt wurde ist was ihr machen schon
gewisse hat behauptete bundesregierung
würde nichts machen das ist natürlich
falsch eine vierköpfige familie die in
hartz4 ist mit zwei kindern und zwei
erwachsenen personen hat diesen monat
oder erhält zum ende diesen monat 600
euro einzahlungen das ist die brücke bis
zu hartz iv und die ganz regulär kommt
ja und es stimmt es stimmt für einige
ist das nichts für einige ist das nicht
erwähnenswert für diese vierköpfige
familie bedeutet es aber einen großen
unterschied nämlich ob sie im sommer
vielleicht noch mal einen ausflug machen
kann und auch der kühlschrank doch etwas
gefüllter ich für diese menschen am
untersee und
wir haben über die aktuelle stunde
beschäftigt sich mit den armutsbericht
des paritätischen verbands und gucken
wir in diesen armutsbericht rhein gibt
es dort erschreckende zahlen die
alarmieren lassen beispielsweise auch
dass die armutsquote bei einer
berufsgruppe so stark angestiegen ist
wie bei den selbstständigen ein anstieg
von 46 prozent im armutsbericht des
paritätischen verbands und das liegt an
der korona politik das liegt daran dass
man mit flächendeckenden lockdown nicht
berücksichtigt welche wirtschaftlichen
und sozialen schäden ist nimmt deswegen
ist es richtig dass wir dort ein
kurswechsel eingeleitet haben
alleinerziehende
sie können so viel strahlen wie sie
wollen sie wissen wir dass spitzenreiter
bei der armutsquote im paritätischen
verbandes das ist bremen das ist dort wo
sie regieren das ist das bundesland aus
über zehn prozent höhere armutsquote hat
wie das bundesland auf platz zwei also
handeln sie gerne in bremen machen die
dort maß für die armut machen sie war
für die wirtschaftliche entwicklung
anstatt sich hier auch zu spielen
und ich möchte ein aspekt noch erläutern
im armutsbericht wird ausschließlich
über die relative armut
gesprochen die relative armut bezeichnet
wenn ein haushalt 60 prozent weniger hat
wie der medialen das ist eine kennzahl
mit der man arbeiten kann man sie zb
eine veränderung bei den selbstständigen
aber sie sagt auch nicht alles aus weil
beispielsweise wenn sich die einkommen
aller bürgerinnen und bürger verdoppeln
würde ist die armutsquote gleich groß in
unserem land deswegen muss man weitere
indikatoren eigentlich dazu
runterzunehmen wie sieht es eigentlich
mit bildungschance sondern unseren land
aus und wenn die cdu sich heute darauf
spielt dann sei auch erwähnt dass die
bildungschancen sich während der
pandemie verschlechtert haben dass sie
nicht
dass sie keine bar für form gemacht
haben obwohl wir die bildungsministerin
carlitscheck erinnert haben
die wahrscheinlichkeit in den 80ern aus
armut aufzusteigen lag bei 40 prozent
man bei niedrigen einkommen war jetzt
liegt die wahrscheinlichkeit auf zu
steigern bei 70 prozent davon weniger es
ist zurückgegangen die
wahrscheinlichkeit in armut zu bleiben
liegt bei 70 prozent das
aufstiegsversprechen ist die wichtigste
frage in der armutsbekämpfung da geht es
schon gute bildung für jeden da geht es
auch um die frage wie effektives ein
sozialstaat wie zielgenau kommt der an
und wir haben viel über erwerbs armut
gesprochen über diejenigen die auf
stärken und die größte leistungs
ungerechtigkeit in unserem land ist wenn
eine alleinerziehende mutter in hartz4
arbeiten geht und sie faktisch mehr als
den spitzensteuersatz zahlen muss
nämlich 80 prozent ihrer arbeit wird auf
die leistungen angerechnet wenn sie mehr
arbeiten will gibt es keine anreize
sondern der staat sagt bleibt in hartz4
befreit ich nicht von der abhängigkeit
des staates nach bitte nichts macht
weniger und deswegen haben wir uns
darauf geeinigt dass die
hinzuverdienstregeln angepasst werden
damit wir leistungen auch von den
belohnen die sich vom sozialstaat
befreien wollen das haben sie 16 jahren
nicht gemacht die beschädigung
zum ende meiner rede möchte ich darauf
eingehen dass mit zwei sachen richtig
sind einmal wir haben die armut im blick
wir sprechen in jedem ausschuss und
jeder ausschusssitzung da darüber und
wir werden auch die weiteren
preisentwicklung überall im über die
sommerpause im blick nehmen und wald und
nur von notwendigkeiten auch jederzeit
ergreifen und zeitgleich gab es aber
auch strukturelle reformen da setzen wir
mit dem bürgergeld an und damit und da
setzen wir auch mit einer anderen
bildungspolitik an denn unser ziel ist
es dass mehr menschen sich von armut
befreien kann weil aufstiegschancen auch
ein wichtiger indikator für
leistungsgerechtigkeit in unserem land
in vielen vielen dank
jetzt holt trainer war das deutliche
kritik an der linksfraktion spielen sie
sich nicht so auf hat er gesagt die
linksfraktion kann jetzt antworten
pascal leyser
wird jetzt hier die nächste rede halten
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren ich frage sie was läuft
eigentlich verkehrt wenn in einem
reichen land wie deutschland fast 14
millionen menschen von armut betroffen
sind wird die zahl der millionäre und
milliardäre von jahr zu jahr immer
weiter steigt was läuft eigentlich
verkehrt wenn der reichste mann in
deutschland seit ausbruch der korona
pandemie über 25 millionen euro
milliarden euro reicher geworden ist
wenn andere ihren job verloren haben und
mit dem kurzarbeitergeld nicht über die
runden gekommen sind jeder sechste geht
inzwischen in deutschland aus
einkommensarmen zu diesem erschreckenden
ergebnis kommt der jüngste armutsbericht
des paritätischen
gesamtverbands eine soziale katastrophe
und es ist ein vernichtendes zeugnis für
all diejenigen die in den letzten jahren
der bundesregierung verantwortung
getragen haben und aktuell zum teil ja
noch weiter verantwortung tragen
ich mir anhöre wie sie von der union mit
der spd in den wettbewerb darüber
eintreten wer die meisten
krokodilstränen darüber vergisst dann
will ich daran erinnern dass den letzten
16 jahren in zwölf jahren sie gemeinsam
wie hier die regierung gestellt haben
und das ist schon bis zum gewissen grade
horchen und ich meine damen und herren
hinter all diesen statistiken stecken
unzählige menschen die schon in der
armutsfalle stecken angesichts aktuell
explodierender preise überhaupt nicht
mehr wissen wie sie ihre miete zahlen
wie sie sich gesund ernähren oder
angemessen kleiden deshalb ist gut dass
die betroffenen nicht mehr länger
schweigen sondern jetzt unter dem
hashtag ich bin armut betroffen und
jetzt auch ein bericht des paritätischen
gesamtverbandes selbst das wort ergreift
frau k eine rentnerin zum beispiel
schreibt wir alten menschen haben der
regel in unseren beruflichen laufbahn
unser bestes gegeben um diese
gesellschaft weiter zu bringen ich finde
keine hacks verdiente im alter als
rentnerin so behandelt zu werden zitat
ende
recht hat sie meine damen
natürlich ist die beständige sorge ob
das geld für sich und die eigene familie
am ende des monats noch reicht für viele
eine schwere psychische belastung frau
ebenfalls armut betroffen schreibt dazu
ich habe gerne nennt panik vor jedem
notfall der geld erfordert oder sind was
kaputt geht zitat ende und dann wird
diesen menschen angesichts der aktuellen
krise gesagt die fetten jahre seien
vorbei sie sollten sparen und sich dabei
am besten noch freudig unterhalten haben
sie eigentlich auch nur die geringste
vorstellung was das bei dem ihnen
auslöst die selbst schon seit jahren in
armut leben müssen ich sagen hören wir
hören sie auf diese menschen und machen
sie endlich politik im interesse dieser
menschen meine damen und
die gründe für diese armut sind
bekanntlich vielfältig sind rentner und
rentner die im alter in armut leben und
flaschen sondern müssen dass die
erwerbslosenzahl beziehen das hin und
vorne nicht reicht aber weit mehr als
ein viertel auf fast vier millionen
menschen der von armut betroffenen
menschen sind sogar erwerbstätig ist die
reinigungskräfte paketbote der pakete im
online boom in alle haustüren ausliefert
es sind auch diejenigen die auf dem
rollfeld gerade dringend gebraucht
werden um den urlaub für diejenigen zu
organisieren die sich in urlaub noch
leisten können und sind noch viele mehr
besonders betroffen junge beschäftigte
befristet beschäftigte und zunehmend
auch solo selbständige sind arm trotz
arbeit und das meine damen und herren
ist doch wirklich überhaupt nicht hin
immer
was wir brauchen
umfassendes programm zur bekämpfung der
armut unserem land dazu gehört
zuallererst dafür zu sorgen dass
diejenigen die hart arbeiten davon noch
anständig leben können und deshalb
es ist gut dass ich die ampel koalition
nach langem zögern unserer langjährigen
forderung nach einer anhebung des
mindestlohns auf 12 euro angeschlossen
dass dies ab oktober endlich realität
wird aber jeder der sich ein bisschen
damit auskennt der weiß natürlich auch
dass das vielleicht für einen single
reicht und gerade so oberhalb der
armutsgrenze über die runden zu kommen
für diejenigen die mit ihrem einkommen
einer familie näher müssen reicht das
hingegen hinten und vorne account wir
reden wir noch nicht davon dass die
inflation immer größere teile auch
dieser lohnsteigerung aufzufressen tot
deshalb müssen sie wenn wir nicht schon
in kürze die nächste erhöhung des
mindestlohns pflege selbst beschließen
wollen dringend dafür sorgen dass
endlich wieder die große mehrheit der
beschäftigten in den genuss einer
bezahlung der tarifvertrag und stärken
sich die verhandlungsmacht der
gewerkschaften
ermöglichen sich die
allgemeinverbindlicherklärung von
tarifverträgen im zweifel auch gegen das
veto der arbeitgeberverbände
zweitens lassen uns dafür sorgen dass
die gesetzliche rente wieder vor armut
im alter schützt mit einem rentenniveau
von 53 prozent und einer echten
höherwertung von niedriglöhnen in die
rente die auch geringverdiener
tatsächlich und an allen ein alten wurde
er laut
drittens natürlich muss auch der
hartz-iv-regelsatz endlich
bedarfsgerecht erhöht werden aber sorgen
soll bitte auch dafür dass menschen die
lange jahre gearbeitet haben und dann
ihren job verlieren gar nicht erst so
schnell auf hartz-iv-niveau abrutschen
das ist doch hochgradig ungerecht
verlängern sie endlich diese zur
lehrling für diejenigen zuvor gearbeitet
haben wieder die bezugsdauer von
arbeitslosengeld 1 und sorgen sie dafür
dass menschen auch wenn sie schon etwas
länger erwerbslos sind eine chance auf
einen wiedereinstieg ins arbeitsleben
bekommt und das heißt aktuell vor allem
stoppen sie die pläne der
bundesregierung vor allem des
finanzministers die
arbeitsmarktprogramme die diesen
menschen eine chance geben auszudrücken
das muss verhindert werden
ich komme zum schluss frau präsidentin
ich sage ihnen sorgen sie dafür dass
endlich alles dafür getan wird dass der
sozialstaat in diesem land tatsächlich
umfassend gegen armut schützt als linke
werden wir uns weiterhin dafür mit aller
kraft einsetzen vielen dank
pascal leyser war das für die
linksfraktion
in nächste rednerin ist annika klose für
die spd fraktion auch sie sitzt im
ausschuss für arbeit und soziales
[Applaus]
der geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
bürgerinnen und bürger wenn man sich
hier im regierungsviertel und der
direkten umgebung so umschaut dann fühlt
sich das thema armut erst mal ganz weit
weg aber keine 15 minuten mit dem
fahrrad von hier entfernt gibt es kekse
in denen mehr als jedes dritte kind in
armut aufwächst mehr als jedes dritte
kind ich finde sein ich finde das in
zahlen da bleibt mir ehrlich gesagt die
spucke weg diese zahlen zeigen
lebensrealitäten auf die unfassbar viele
menschen betreffen auch im eigenen
umfeld was man aber oft nicht wahr ist
nicht direkt sieht oder worüber auch
wenig gesprochen wird denn armut ist in
unserem land leider immer noch ein sehr
stigmatisiert das thema viele menschen
schämen sich dafür von armut betroffen
zu sein und auch hilfe in anspruch zu
nehmen dabei müssten sich eigentlich
nicht die betroffenen für irgendetwas
schämen soll es sind wir alle als
gesellschaft die davon betroffen sein
sollten dass in einem so reichen in
deutschland so viele menschen in armut
leben
aber eben sein
auch nach wie vor mit stigmatisierung
von stigmatisierung behaftet ist es ist
umso wichtiger das ist berichte gibt wie
diesen den wir heute diskutieren der ist
den akuten handlungsbedarf immer wieder
schwarz auf weiß vor augen führt daher
vielen dank an den paritätischen
gesamtverband für den diesjährigen
armutsbericht der
bereich zeigt armut ist nach wie vor ein
umfassendes problem in deutschland und
auch die zahl armer und von armut
bedrohter kinder und jugendlicher nimmt
in deutschland seit jahren immer weiter
zu die armut unter kindern und
jugendlichen hat in diesem jahr mit 20,8
prozent einen neuen traurige rekordmarke
erreicht damit lebt fast jedes fünfte
kind und uns eigentlich sehr reichen
land in armut das ist ein zustand werte
kolleginnen und kollegen und liebe
bundesregierung der defizit definitiv so
nicht bleiben kann
wir alle wissen und keine als
sozialdemokrat ist mir das natürlich
schmerzlich bewusst welche gravierenden
folgen armut gerade für die entwicklung
von jungen menschen hat armut bedeutet
armut bedeutet in unserem land einen
schlechteren zugang zu bildung weniger
freizeitmöglichkeiten denke wo
verhältnisse schlechteres essen und mehr
gesundheitliche probleme all diese
umstände machen es für junge menschen
enorm schwer aus eigener kraft der
armutsfalle zu bekommen wer hier in
armut aufwächst hat schlechtere
startvoraussetzungen und das kann sich
im gesamten lebenslauf auswirkungen dass
es extrem ungerecht und diese seit
jahren um diese seit jahren negative
entwicklung der kinder und jugendarbeit
endlich umzukehren und so auch für mehr
chancengerechtigkeit zu sorgen braucht
es ein ziel gerechtes und steuern in
unserer sozialpolitik wir brauchen
endlich eine politik die junge menschen
und ihre wünsche und bedarfe in den
mittelpunkt stellen und da möchte ich
sagen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von
der linken genau das werden wir nämlich
auch tun deswegen haben wir uns nämlich
in dieser legislaturperiode vorgenommen
endlich eine kindergrundsicherung zu
einzuführen die unbürokratischen
diese neue sozialleistung sondern gutes
aufwachsen für alle jungen menschen
unabhängig von ihrem elternhaus
ermöglichen sie soll einfach zugänglich
und transparent sein und sie soll kinder
und jugendlichen in allen lebenslagen
vor armut schützen egal ob sie unter den
mieten oder im wedding aufwachsen die
kinder und jugendarmut ist aber
natürlich nur einer der armuts
brennpunkte die dieser bericht aufzeigt
und bei den erwerbslosen ist die
arbeitsgruppe besonders hoch ebenso wie
bei den seniorinnen zu suchen und bei
den menschen mit migrations biografie
und ebenso wie bei der kinder- und
jugendarmut geht auch hier dass wir auch
für diese gruppen nachhaltige konzepte
und größere weichenstellung brauchen um
die armut endlich zu überwinden und auch
da kann ich wieder sagen genau daran
arbeiten wir doch genau mit dieser
bundesregierung und mit der
kindergrundsicherung mit dem neuen
bürger in geld was wir einführen werden
und mit einem arbeits armutsfesten
mindestens von 12 euro denke schon
beschlossen haben
damit werden wir eben diese weichen
stellen und damit hoffe ich dass wir in
den nächsten jahren in den armutsbericht
'niemand trendumkehr in dieser
armutsspirale feststellen werden
nächster redner für die cdu csu fraktion
dr markus reiche
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen vielleicht mal
ganz am anfang und ich versuche das
jetzt ruhig zu sagen damit sie dann
nachher nicht sagen wir von der cdu/csu
blasen uns da immer so auf aber er tritt
trine sie haben ja eine ganze reihe von
dingen
angesprochen bildungsgerechtigkeit
aufstieg chancen und ich finde da haben
sie genau recht das sind genau die
punkte über die wir sprechen müssen auf
die erklärung wie sie mit einem tank
rabatt genau das unterstützen wollen da
warten wir natürlich noch lang also das
bitten wir uns das mal erklären
und auch liebe prognose das ist
wunderbar was sie an plänen darstellen
wir werden darauf dass auch tatsächlich
wenn sie das mal auch in den
haushaltsentwürfe dann zeigen dass sie
darin konkret arbeiten und konzepte
vorlegen wir sind sehr gespannt
so meine damen und herren also wir sind
uns glaube ich alle einig dass das
worüber wir heute sprechen dass jeder
fall und wir haben doch alle jetzt wir
kennen fälle wir haben fälle zitiert wo
es darum geht dass jemand gegen sein
willen mit einem niedrigen einkommen
lebt und nicht aus diesen verhältnissen
herauskommen und besonders schlimm ist
das natürlich bei den kindern denn die
sind ja quasi noch weniger in der lage
das selbst zu ändern und wenn wir jetzt
aber darüber sprechen und ich wundere
mich dass der begriff heute noch nicht
einmal gefallen ist müssen wir uns doch
daran erinnern an diesem platz vor vier
monaten hat bundeskanzler scholz davon
gesprochen dass wir in einer zeitenwende
leben
und ich meine wir müssen uns doch auch
die frage stellen was bedeutet denn eine
diskussion über armut in einer
zeitenwende
also konkret wie schaffen wir es dass
wir unsere sozialsysteme
solidarisch halten dass wir es aber auch
bezahlbar halten und ich meine schon
dass wir uns einig sein sollten dass wir
da nicht einfach so weitermachen können
wie bisher
eine krise und der sind
eindeutig in einer krise ist die
verpflichtung und bietet aber auch die
chance und aufgabe sich auf das
wesentliche zu konzentrieren die
menschen über die wir sprechen sind
wesentlich für uns aber in einer krise
wird man nicht alles einfach mit mehr
geld aus dem staatshaushalt lösen können
sondern wir müssen uns auf die wirklich
bedürftigen konzentrieren und wir müssen
uns von unsinnigen regeln trennen die
uns davon abhalten
in dieser diskussion hat aber die ampel
koalition eben noch keine vorschläge
gemacht und ich gebe ihnen gerne gleich
ein paar beispiele
so jetzt in diesem beitrag wollen wir ja
auch über die dem paritätischen
wohlfahrtsverband
diskutieren nicht nur finanzielle
aspekte sind wichtig das haben sie sehr
gut herausgearbeitet hat der trainer
sondern es geht eben auch darum armut an
wertschätzung armut an aufgaben armut an
anforderungen das ist doch was letzten
endes dann dieses gesamtkomplex von
armut und für uns als union ist das
letzten endes dass wir sagen fördern und
fordern das muss zusammengedacht werden
und deswegen sage ich ihnen auch
sanktionen aufzuheben das war schlecht
sanktionen aufzugeben das heißt letzten
endes menschen aufgeben
und ich frage sie ist das wirklich ihre
vorstellung von zeitenwende und jetzt
liebe frau kollegin drei punkte um das
mal zu unterlegen zunächst einmal
entlastungspaket dass hier in der
aktuellen informations krise von 29
milliarden euro in den entlastungs
paketen 2 milliarden euro bei den
wirklich bedürftigen angekommen ist das
ist meines erachtens da sind sich
schlicht am thema vorbei das geht so
nicht
weiter
wir müssen unser sozialsystem einfacher
und besser machen aber nicht einfach
teurer hier geht es darum natürlich das
wurde auch angesprochen wir müssen bei
den regelsätzen daran denken wie wir sie
rasch anpassen können hartz 4 die
zuverdienstregeln oder wie wir uns auf
langzeitarbeitslose entsprechend mehr
konzentrieren können indem wir die
mitarbeiter in den jobcentern von der
überwachung von überbordender bürokratie
abhalten oder bildungsteilhabe paket
besser an die bedürftigen haben
das sind punkte und dritter punkt das
möchte ich ihnen schon auch noch sagen
basis für alles worüber wir sprechen ist
solidarität mit den hilfsbedürftigen
aber auch mit den leistungsträgern und
leistungsträger das sind nicht nur die
reichen das sind auch die kleinen und
mittleren einkommen der bäcker der
vielleicht auch noch brötchen zu das
kindergartenfest bringt die
physiotherapeutin die mit ihrem auto
rentner noch zum begegnungszentrum fährt
das parallel dazu dass sie auch noch
jeden tag ihre steuern zahlt weniger
bürokratie regelung mit augenmaß
steuerliche entlastung sie das
angesprochen machen sie so aus sie haben
die minister also das wird uns dahin
bringen und wenn wir daran an diese drei
punkte denken dann werden die auch als
solidarische gesellschaft gemeinsam
durch diese krise kommen vielen dank für
ihre aufmerksamkeit
nächster redner für die fraktion bündnis
90 die grünen frank bsirske frank
bsirske ja auch sehr bekannt als verdi
vorsitzender bis 2019 und jetzt sprecher
für arbeit und soziales der spd der
grünen fraktion
wir haben es gehört
2020 hat die armut in deutschland einen
neuen höchststand erreicht noch nie
wurden am markt trug mikrozensus eine
höhere armutsquote in deutschland
gemessen
13,8 millionen menschen leiden unter
armut
und in dieser zahl ist die verschärfung
der lage
im weiteren verlauf der pandemie und ist
der enorme preisanstieg im zeichen
fossile inflation noch gar nicht
abgebildet
und was steht dem auf der kehrseite
gegenüber
ein enormer zuwachs privaten reichtums
und eine fortschreitende
vermögenskonzentration
das reichste prozent der bevölkerung
besitzt mittlerweile über 35 prozent des
privaten vermögens
allein die dax unternehmen
verzeichneten 2021 einen gewinn von 170
milliarden euro und schütten aktuell 70
milliarden euro an dividenden aus und
das vermögen der zehn reichsten
deutschen familien stieg während der
pandemie um satte 40 prozent auf nunmehr
230 milliarden euro wenn bei der
süddeutschen zeitung glauben schenken
wollen
stetig zunehmende konzentration privaten
reichtums dort stetige zunahme der armut
lebenden hier
2006 lag die armutsquote noch bei 14,0
prozent 2020 waren es bereits 16,1 arm
sein
das heißt schon dass hier schon vor
corinna jeden euro zweimal umdrehen zu
müssen im zeichen von corona sind
weitere belastung hinzu gekommen ist die
not noch größer geworden arm sein das
heißt einem höheren krankheits
erkrankungsrisiko ausgesetzt zu sein das
heißt
zusätzliche aufwendungen bewältigen zu
müssen aus ohnehin unzureichenden
mitteln sich das nötigste vom munde
absparen zu müssen und gleichzeitig mit
dem wegfall vieler
unterstützungsangebote konfrontiert zu
sein vom sozialkaufhaus über die tafeln
bis hin zum schulessen und jetzt
getrieben durch den zustrom geflutet aus
der ukraine und die verteuerung alles
lebensnotwendige
hat sie die lage weiter dramatisch
verschärft das trifft alleinerziehende
trifft erwerbslose auch kinderreiche
paarhaushalte und frauen im alter
besonders
und trägt dazu bei dass mittlerweile 25
prozent der bundesbürgerinnen den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt
ernsthaft bedroht sehen
zwingt uns das zu handeln ja in der tat
reagiert hat ja bereits auch die groko
wenngleich unter führung der union viel
zu spät
dauert das ist doch bis maine und 2021
bis endlich alle hartz 4 und
grundsicherungs beziehenden wenigstens
einen einmaligen betrag von 150 euro
ausbezahlt bekommen das hat die ampel
anders gemacht und sich schon und
koalitionsvertrag auf eine anhebung des
gesetzlichen mindestlohns verpflichtet
auf die anhebung der windows rente auf
die dauerhafte stabilisierung des
rentenniveaus auf verbesserungen beim
bafög beim wohngeld auf ein bürgergeld
und die kindergrundsicherung und wir
haben geliefert haben schnell zwei
entlastungs paket geschnürt mit
verlängerung des kurzarbeitergeldes öpnv
ticket heizkostenzuschuss 200 euro für
transferleistungen bezieherinnen
kinderbonus in der zuschuss und weiteren
das bringt spürbare entlastung und zwar
insbesondere zugunsten unterer und
mittlerer einkommen denn auch mit einer
schwachstelle bei der
nichterwerbstätigen
vieles davon erreicht die menschen nun
ab juli das ist gut und auch sehr nötig
wird das aber reichen jetzt wo die
preise durch die decke gehen und das
grab zu einem lieferstopp russischen
gases und zu weiteren preisanstieg
kommen könnte wohl kaum
weiterer handlungsbedarf zeichnet sich
deutlich ab wobei eines ganz klar ist
wir können mit staatlichen mitteln nicht
allen alles ausgleichen umso nötiger ist
es die entlastungsmaßnahmen auf die zu
konzentrieren jetzt am dringendsten
brauchen auf dem menschen in der
grundsicherung und im hartz-iv-bezug und
auch die mit den geringen und mittleren
einkommen und sie sahen aber ganz ruhig
wird ja rentenpolitik die dazu geführt
hat dass wenn wir so weitermachen würden
millionen von menschen trotz
jahrzehntelanger beitragszahlung auf
oder auf grundsicherungsniveau sinken
würden das ist etwas was wir nicht
wollen damit
damit verbietet es nicht
denn hier die entlastungsmaßnahmen auf
die konzentrieren diesen diensten
brauchen verbietet das richtigkeit der
progression angehen zu wollen denn die
verteilungswirkung dabei ist krass
einseitig 50 prozent geben den höchsten
einkommen zugute weitere 16 prozent dem
zweitgrößten wir haben bei den unteren
drei zehnteln so gut wie nichts ankommt
das ist das genaue gegenteil von dem was
jetzt nötig ist was ist braucht ist ein
zuschlag auf die regelsätze
transferleistung beziehende sinn machen
kann eine erneut progressiv besteuert
energie geld pauschale die sonne aber
auch für nicht erwerbsfähige gelten
müsste und nachzudenken
ist über ein gast und eventuell eindruck
passt deckel auf eine grundbedarf menge
gegebenenfalls sozial gestaffelt das
wird in den kommenden monaten zu
konkretisieren sein wird das geld kosten
ja wird das womöglich viel geld kosten
müssen ja auch dass das wirkt dann aber
auch die frage auf ob das überhaupt
zusammenpassen kann den 2023 zur
schuldenbremse zurückkehren zu wollen
auf steuererhöhungen starken in der
gesellschaft zu verzichten die
investition für digitalisierung und
transformation mastbruch zu fahren und
menschen in not und armut und da die
arbeit zugreifen und ebenso den mit den
geringen und mittleren einkommen seien
sie sicher die ampel wird sie auch
dieser herausforderung stellen
sagt frank bsirske für die grünen das
thema armut in deutschland wird uns
bestimmt noch häufiger leider
beschäftigen bei 13 8 millionen armer
menschen hier im land wir verlassen den
deutschen bundestag eigentlich soll es
anfang september die nächste
sitzungswoche geben andererseits
angesichts der nationalen und
internationalen lage gibt es schon jetzt
vorwarnungen das ist zu sondersitzungen
kommen könnte sollte dem so sein
berichten wir auf phoenix natürlich auch
wieder darüber